[Applause]
the Alabama's special election between
Roy Moore and Doug Jones was last night
it's a small unimportant local election
and we haven't really been talking about
that much the fake news MSM and all
media are claiming a victory for the
democrat doug jones just just because
it's technically over but the truth is
this race is still it still feels too
close to call
when the vote is this close that it's
not over I had a feeling he wasn't going
to concede because it just the numbers
aren't adding up that's what we've got
to do is wait on God and let this
process play out yes you go Roy God
takes his time it took him two days to
build the earth he spent the other five
days building America drawing
congressional districts is surprisingly
difficult but it's fine this is not a
loss I mean even in the extreme long
shot of doug jones somehow winning he
has to face another election in two
years he's already a lame duck which is
the exact thing that Roy Moore hunts
with his extremely alpha micro gun so
just to sum up the results of this
election are totally non conclusive they
barely even matter anyway and I am in no
way concerned about what this means for
the future of the populous Trump
revolution well nothing much left to
talk about the fight continues after
this
mother
[Applause]
get back a new judge like what happened
last night
look behind you do you see a liberal
good we lost them this right here this
is just between us guys we lost and I
hate it in Alabama Alabama went to a
Democrat are you the reddest state
they're so red
they only recently started using the
pronoun she' it doesn't make sense I
can't I can't wrap my head around it how
did this guy the guy that I Steve Bannon
and the president got behind loose do we
back the wrong guy do we need to take a
moment and really analyze the type of
person we're hitching our wagon to know
it don't have time for the hats
it can't be our fault the blame has to
lie elsewhere
someone costs Roy Moore this election
but whom or even worse who
God gave me ten blame casters and it's
time to finger some bad guys suspect
number one Steve Bannon Steve Bannon the
president's chief political advisor
during the campaign was wrong after
Alabama disaster GOP must do right thing
and dump Steve Bannon this guy does not
belong on the national stage he looks
like some disheveled drunk people at the
White House where you hear is like
devastating and also suggesting the
president has egg on his face because of
his former adviser Steve Bannon what the
President does not have egg on his face
it's egg McMuffin and it's technically
on his neck
Steve Bannon engineered Roy Moore's
kandacy but blaming Bannon is too easy
he's the only person we know is innocent
it's never the obvious suspect haven't
you seen a Shyamalan movie
Baden's been dead this whole time let me
just look at him
yeah plus bright Bart's front page
reports Bannon least culpable you can
trust that because that website is run
by Steve Bannon himself
so so who sabotage row more next suspect
the swamp a very senior GOP source on
the hill thinks that this is Mitch
McConnell's fault both Paul Ryan and
Mitch McConnell are major problems for
the president Republican Senator Jeff
Flake of Arizona sent this $100 check to
Moore's Democratic opponent Doug Jones
riding on the memo line of the check
country over party ah country over party
is not only a dangerous 1,700 sex
position it's also a rallying cry for
wimpy moderates like flake next suspect
to blame for Roy Moore's loss horse
Twitter now no Roy Moore wrote a horse
to his polling place which is standard
and the mean world of the Internet
specifically the horse internet decided
to go all in on him saying that his
forum sucks and any horse person can see
he's a fake cowboy you know what maybe
I'm overthinking it maybe this is just a
referendum on Trump wrong
I never overthink I am an under thinker
am i right facts this was not a
referendum on Trump I feel like it was a
referendum on Harvey Weinstein Weinstein
okay oh okay so that's the alleged
predator everyone's been talking about
okay Weinstein must have forced his way
into the Alabama election without its
consent and activated a cabal of silence
breaking women who mistakenly voted
against Roy Moore
but how could women keep Roy Moore out
of the Senate I mean it's not a mall
you know what I think I found the prime
suspect a secret group that wields great
power and hides in plain sight who work
specifically on behalf of mainstream
Democrats to steal elections and daytime
talk shows black women Jones 198 to 2 it
was a black women that puts Doug Jones
over the hump this victory was delivered
to us by black women that's it I know
who sabotage Rome or Senate campaign
black women in fact 98% of black Alabama
women voted against Roy Moore last night
they colluded to take him down
this is voter suppression they voted to
suppress Roy Moore this was a stinging
rebuke by black voters to someone who
really would have turned the clock back
a hundred years in Alabama that's not
fair no no Roy Moore didn't want to turn
the clock back a hundred years that is
slander he specifically said that the
last time America was great was during
slavery which was at least 200 years ago
who looks stupid now opposers I've
stumbled onto something big here black
women came together for Obama against
Trump and this me too movement that
targets innocent tiny Cowboys like Roy
Moore Google it
scratch that Bing it a black woman
started that - yeah 20 years ago
her name is tirana Burke and here I've
been angrily tweeting at Alyssa Milano
and Rose McGowan I mean I take it back
charmed was a fine TV series with
adequate special effects let's move on
so when it comes to what happened in
Alabama last night as much as clear
powerful organized black women are
coming for us and we need to be prepared
we need hardcore recon to investigate
this emerging threat but it will be
challenging there is surprisingly little
mainstream literature TV or films about
them like at all and also they don't
live in my neighborhood because my
congressional district is shaped like a
spaghetti noodle
but here's the plan if conservatives
want to retain power we need to find out
how black women manage this political
coup I know what they want and what they
don't want
maybe I'll embed on one of those girls
trips I've heard so much about I'm going
to wiretap the movement I'm going to use
all of my surveillance because if we
want to make America great again we need
to listen to black women
[Music]